[Music]
hey guys George Campbell here with
another minute money hack I'm here at
Cody's automotive in Franklin Tennessee
and I'm super revved up to talk about
car hacks today now I know you're
thinking what does George know about CV
joint boosts intake manifold gaskets and
clutch pack pistons well I know less
than you think that's why I have friends
like Cody
hey Cody here's how this works I'm gonna
start the clock and we're gonna take
this thing from 0 to 60 seconds in well
60 seconds let's do it here we go don't
overpay for gas you can download a
smartphone app like gas buddy to find
the cheapest gas near you also you can
use a GPS app like Waze or Google Maps
to avoid traffic jams and find the best
routes while you're at it some shops
will repair your tire for free
regardless of where you bought it
speaking of tire pressure your
recommended tire pressure is actually in
your door jamb usually it's around 32
psi I like to run mine around 34 35
you'll get a little better fuel economy
that way to clean your teeth and your
headlights with the same product good
old-fashioned toothpaste just rub some
on a damp cloth and put a little elbow
grease in it I like to use lemon pledge
it works great and it smells good too
use an app like RetailMeNot to find
great deals on oil changes near you a
lot of shops lose money on oil changes
so don't get sucked into unnecessary
repairs don't overpay for car insurance
check out our friends at Zander
insurance com they shop the top
companies to find you the best rates
thanks to Cody at Cody's automotive
anytime George and there's your minute
money hack
[Music]